well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages uh time then to see what is
making the headlines with the columnist
carol malone and the editor of the
courier in dundee david clegg with us
from now until just before midnight and
welcome to both of you
so first of all let's see what's on the
front pages
according to the financial times
centrica the owner of british gas is
urging the government to give customers
more support with their energy costs
even though centrica's year-to-year
earnings have gone up five-fold the star
takes a dim view calling the likes of
british gas and shell money grabbing
scumbags the guardian leading with the
reaction of trade unions to the profits
as an insult to working people
profits in misery is how the daily
mirror sees it
the express meanwhile carries rishi
sunak's pledge to deport more than 5 000
foreign criminals out of the country if
he becomes prime minister the daily mail
goes with the closure of what's been
deemed an unsafe nhs child gender clinic
while the telegraph reports that the nhs
could be banned from giving puberty
blockers to children for fear of rushing
them into changing gender
davis paper the courier reports on
concerns in the dundee area that the
cost of living crisis could lead to even
more drug-related deaths than the 1300
plus recorded there last year the metro
leading with the trial of a group of met
police officers associated with wayne
cousins the officer jailed for murdering
sarah everard
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's discuss those papers
in more detail tonight joined by carol
malone and david clegg welcome to both
of you
um carol to the ft we go first of all um
centrica the owner of british gas urging
more state help um eon we spoken to
suggesting that 40 of its customers
could go into fuel poverty and such are
the fears for customers this winter
yeah and their fears are the fears are
justified we just heard today that you
know most families are facing bills of
oh god look at my glasses bills have
something like 500 quid every single
month which is astonishing you know and
centrica which is owned by british gas
has an absolute cheek asking for state
up this is a company who a year ago in
the first quarter made 262 million
profit now that's gone up to 1.34
billion it's astonishing and you know
and all the other companies are the same
and it's very easy for the boss of
centric there's a guy called chris
o'shea he was quoted recently saying
money doesn't motivate me when he was
when he was challenged about his vast
salary well no it doesn't motivate you
when you're on 875 grand a year and last
year he got a five million quid bonus
and we're talking and they have the
cheek to say to ask the state for help
which i i just find out rage and a lot
of mps have come out today and said this
is this is beyond obscene it's greed and
and yet they're they're saying as they
always do these companies that where the
profits are it's not in the consumer arm
of their business it's in the nuclear
and oil and gas business which is not
about consumers but you know what when
you're making that much profit you could
pass some of it on to the people who've
made you very rich
i mean yeah this is interesting isn't it
it's francis o'grady isn't it the
general secretary of the tuc we see it
there in the guardian energy firms
profit surges insulting uh for working
people and she was suggesting david that
energy bills are rising 23 times faster
than wages it's time she said for profit
restraint not lectures on wage restraint
again similar for the daily star
and yet uh british gas itself uh which
is part of the centrica group um found
that its profits operating profits
actually fell by 43 partly because
they've had to take on all of those
customers um you know of those failing
energy companies um and they're
supplying those uh houses that are lost
now and in fact our business presenter
ian king pointing out that every
household it has it has eight million of
them british cash only makes a profit of
just six pounds per customer so i mean
this is the the dichotomy isn't it shell
likewise some of those profits are in
it's on most of the profits and it's
global business so where do you draw the
line here
you're making a valiant effort to uh put
across the gas company's perspective and
and make people feel sorry for them but
i feel it may also be a doomed effort i
think what has been uh quite striking
about the coverage in this and the
general public conversation about it is
you know from from the conservative
party right three to the trade union
movement there's a great deal of anger
and unease about this i think uh when
you see those type of profit figures
being recorded whenever people are
really struggling when as as as carol
said we're looking at
average
gas and energy bills of up to four
thousand pounds it's just a absolutely
unbelievable situation to be in and
crystal shame had made an attempt today
to say i know it is going to be awkward
hearing about dividends and profit being
passed on to shareholders when when
people are struggling like that well yes
it is and what you're going to do about
it i think is the question so when you
have this idea in the financial times
about them calling for more state help i
i don't really think that uh is going to
wash it may be the case that even with a
quite a significant move for a
conservative government with the the
tax that they're introducing uh on the
energy companies it still isn't enough
that may that may be the case but
equally whenever profits are being
recorded like that they're they're going
to need to do a lot more to help their
customers to help people who are going
to be uh absolutely struggling to heat
their homes this winter and i i don't
really feel they're going to get
sympathy anywhere uh so
in a in a situation where people are
this concerned
really really worried and
certainly at the career our mailbag is
full of readers who are you know have
never seen this type of skill uh a rise
in energy costs you know with up to five
times what the bills were a year ago
that is just not sustainable for people
who who were struggling to begin with so
yes the the the uk government and then
scotland the scottish government is
going to have to take more steps to help
these people but equally these companies
which are making not millions but
billions of pounds are going to have to
do a lot more as well yes the ft
pointing out that another round of
record profits could prop calls for
again extra levies on energy groups bp
they say also expected uh to disclose a
strong performance in the coming days
but i will persist if you don't mind
david
pointed out there um then actually one
of the industry bodies i heard today
said this this crisis is not just one of
affordability it is the one of keeping
the lights on now where will this energy
come from is actually starting to be a
big question as we head into the winter
the national grid talks about tightness
for example in december this year so you
know this this is also a pressing matter
about about energy supply carol
yeah it absolutely is i mean there's a
story's broken today that in hanover
it's the first city in germany that is
now they're putting they're putting it
they're rationing their their their
energy so they're planning hot water
they're buying central heating in sen in
public buildings they're banning um
central lincoln swimming pools in gyms
and and very you know that things like
air conditioning things you can't use
now because they have been hit
hellishly hard by the fact they were
totally they were almost totally
dependent on gas from russia and in in
june this year uh putin stopped the the
supply he cut the supply to 40 on the
nordstrom pipe and this month he's cut
it to 20 so germany is in real trouble
and they're saying the euro zone is
going to be ditto so that they have the
problem already that we will soon um be
experiencing ourselves i don't know what
we do about that because you know we do
we know we don't get a lot of we don't
get ours from from russia not much of it
anyway but we're still going to feel the
knock-on effects so it's terrifying for
people not only are they having to pay
through the nose for whatever energy it
is they get they might not have enough
of it then we might have to go into
russians in the depths of winter which
is terrifying and that makes the way
these energy bosses are talking all the
more calling i mean they literally you
know they talk like they understand what
it's like for someone on on a low income
no they have no idea and they have
little sympathy either judging by the
comments i've seen from some of them
today you know just
have a look at some of the salaries that
these these fat cast energy bosses are
on you've got chris o'shea who's central
gear he's on 875. you've got keith
anderson who scottish power 1.15 million
michael lewis ceo of vmware a million
quid they're all on generally a million
quid how on earth do they know what it's
like not to be able to pay a gas or
electricity bill they have no idea
we reported on recently uh is a
pensioner who was using her bus pass to
to go around in the bus because it was
warm in the bus and she didn't have to
heat her house and this this is this is
happening 30 miles from aberdeen the oil
capital and the energy capital of europe
there's there is something absolutely
obscene about that and it does it does
depend on global factors which are
beyond the control
of any one government or organization
but it certainly demands uh an
incredible effort and response whether
that be a policy response from
government uh and
institutional organizational response
from these energy firms because this
this is a this is a terrible uh tragedy
that's unfolding and it needs to be
dealt with very quickly
yes we see uh the daily mirror there we
may have seen it already but uh profits
and misery as millions struggle to pay
their bills shell and centrica make the
paper describes it as obscene amounts of
money um the problem is that petrol you
know is probably high in this country
because of taxes so what do our two
candidates vying for the post do about
it and is government focused on looking
ahead to properly help people who are
already beginning to think about not
affording to put the kettle on carol
rather than even heating heating their
homes so you know who's planning for
this right now are we a country run by
civil servants
well i think we are and i don't think
the two people vying for the the
premiership are planning for anything
other than their ascendancy into the job
and this this was always going to be the
problem wasn't it with it with a
leadership battle right now it's what
boris actually warned about this was not
the time to do it this was the time to
be planning a strategy for winter to
help all those desperate people and
we're not doing that what the what that
what our politicians are doing is
deciding which camp they're going to
jump into the soon i call the trust
count and then they're you know they're
they're vying for they're trying to help
them and it it i was watching the
hustings tonight it really makes me
angry they're sitting there talking
about the fantasy things they're going
to do all the things they're going to do
in the future when the biggest problem
right now for most of the people in this
country how they're going to heat their
homes come october yeah well that's what
we uh where our discussion will head
next after the break the first of the
hustings today liz truss and rishi sunak
are facing an audience of tory party
members in leeds we'll discuss that
after this
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me this evening carol
malone and david clegg welcome back to
both of you um so the first hustings uh
rishi sunak liz truss in leeds her home
turf david i guess you could say um and
the articles are sort of playing to
their audience are they not for example
the metro um tory rivals battle for
votes on rail and green belt plans
including this trust on housing so tell
us more about your thoughts on tonight
yes i think i think part of what we're
seeing particularly coming out in that
hustlings which was to touring members
who as we know the people who are going
to decide who the next prime minister is
it won't be the country at large it will
be that very small subset of people who
are members of the conservative party is
the dynamics of that contest inevitably
mean that they have to pitch towards the
tory members and the views or at least
the perceived views of tory members so i
think we saw in a whole host of things
today i was particularly struck by rishi
sunak who as we know i was the most
popular candidate with the mps but
actually uh polling suggests is is is
the underdog when it comes to the tory
membership he he was backing a return of
grammar schools today which i is i i i
thought was a really stark proposal
given you know it felt like that
conversation had really been closed and
uh
whether the public at large given what
we've been discussing earlier uh this
evening believe that that is a priority
right now i i struggle to believe that
and from my perspective as well i
thought his answer on scotland was
really interesting because it showed the
same thing again i think which is this
uh suspicion that they're playing
towards the tory membership so he was
asked about scottish nationalism the
scottish independence question that goes
sturgeons calls for another independence
referendum and it's described it as a
seductive idea and said that they need
to battle back using emotion as well now
anyone who's spoken to anyone who was
involved in the in the first new
campaign the first campaign to keep the
uk together news that actually every
anyone who's who's uh
seduced or excited by the idea of flags
and braveheart and uh reenacting
bannockburn is already voting for
independence and the people that you
need to you need to play for here the
people who are undecided are much more
realistic and are worried about the
economic issues that we've been
discussing tonight so again it was i
think playing for a touring membership
rather than playing to the
to the public at large and that that's
fine for this contest and that may uh
that may help him
make up ground with liz trust but what
of course it won't do if it begins to be
setting policy for his administration or
her administration going forwards is
give policies that are likely to in a
general election so i think from a
conservative perspective i would be
concerned about that okay david you make
a good point daily express um similar
you know you're preaching to your
audience i guess on this one as well
aren't you just quickly carol
yeah everybody yeah he's saying he'll
kick them out he says he'll double the
amount he's going to kick out well that
would be about 10. if that's going to be
the case you know he can promise all
this stuff if it was that easy to do
pretty patel would have done it and so
would have boris you know i i don't
believe anything any of them are saying
i just you know if anyone had told me
six months ago that these two this was
going to be our choice of these two very
very
um what's the word boring dull people
average people to run our country
out of laughing said it can't be true
but you know i'm looking at liz trust is
our next prime minister and it it
devastates me and it really upsets me
because the electorate didn't pick her
that you know they won't want her okay
we can see as time goes on
there's still a lot of boris fans out
there okay um carol and david thank you
both very much indeed for that